Eric Pinault vous vous intéressez aux
questions de transition écologique
depuis un an certains notent un
changement de temps dans les rapports du
GIEC et de l'IPBES explique-nous ce
changement de temps c'est c'est un
changement qui est un appel à des
transformations systémiques et une
action sur les causes sous-jacentes à la
fois la crise climatique avec la crise
de biodiversité c'est qu'au sous-jacente
c'est nos institutions économiques et je
dirais la grande percée là cette
année-là dans le dernier cycle d'études
du GIEC et ça peut être la même chose
pour les pbs en biodiversité de mettre
en question la croissance et la demande
en général en matériaux en service aux
écosystèmes que nos économies ont de
manière intéressante de dire
on en demande trop on n'a pas de limite
à notre à l'expansion de l'extraction de
la disparition de matière de de ce qu'on
demande aux écosystèmes en termes de
service et les pbs est rendu au même
conclusion que si on veut atteindre
freiner la crise l'érosion de la
biodiversité il va falloir envisager des
limites matérielles à l'expansion de nos
économies ce qui est surprenant c'est
que ça vienne de corps scientifique
comme les pbls ou le JF moi c'est ce qui
me frappe le plus en fait c'est que la
communauté scientifique mais précisément
cette partie de la communauté qui plutôt
en sciences naturelles des gens de
laboratoire des gens qui sont eux rendus
porteur d'un discours de changement
social et d'alerte et d'urgence ça ça me
fera ça samedi quelque chose je
m'attends on m'aurait dit ça il y a 15
ans dans le nouveau cadre mondial il y a
des objectifs très spécifiques qui
s'attaquent à ces questions de valeur
économiques là est-ce que c'est
suffisant ce qu'il y a dans le cadre
mondial en ce moment je pense que c'est
un premier pas la COP15 et les
négociations du cadre sont en occasion
pour avoir et je pense que c'est ce qui
va arriver à Montréal un débat de
société un débat sur notre modèle de
développement sur ça veut dire quoi un
niveau de vie écologiquement soutenable
et juste par rapport au reste de la
planète la transition écologique au
Québec elle va impliquer les
transformations profondes on va utiliser
moins d'énergie on va vivre différemment
on va se déplacer différemment
travailler des différemment nos
entreprises vont avoir sûrement des
nouvelles règles
la règle du profit va sûrement être
moins importante que d'autres règles en
termes de qualité en termes de
diminution d'impact en termes de
travailler avec la nature plutôt que
contre la nature en terme de circularité
peu importe tous ces règles-là je pense
peuvent être discuter dans le cadre
d'une
transition et la COP et l'occasion pour
ouvrir le débat merci beaucoup